you guys this is my favorite movie there
Oh movie of the year you say that's all
the producer no no I don't how am I
supposed to save the whole world why did
you feel that Miles Morales was the
story they wanted to tell gosh I mean it
just seems like a great extension of the
legacy of Stan Lee and Steve Ditko
writing a story about you know a
middle-class kid from Queens in 60s is a
really radical thing to try it was a
nerdy teenager yeah and he's not like
any little he's not qualified
he doesn't feel qualified and he thinks
some of this is ridiculous and he was
just a regular person and and they
really you know Stan Lee's like legacy
is to like really democratize this genre
and and this kind of miss making and
that's really important to us and and we
thought that what Bendis and Pacelli did
with spider-man in the book was you know
was so special you mentioned Stan Lee
this is the first movie since its
passing and I thought his cameo was like
so poignant and perfect can you guys
talk about what went into making that
kami I was opposed to you know we see a
lot of like gags on TV yeah well because
this movie is so much about the logical
extension of the thing that Dan created
at the very beginning we knew we wanted
to do something special with his cameo
not just have it be something off to the
side really like oh there he is
we want it to be a moment that we that
would Vance the plot and was it a really
emotional crux of the film and when we
came upon the idea that he would be
where he is in the film
it seemed exactly right that he was
passing on the legacy and out and we
were honoring honoring him and all the
things that he had done and of course
when we screen this you know for the
first time at New York Comic Con in
October and he was still alive it was
such a warm happy cheer and and and a
laugh and now it's all of those things
the laugh and the cheer but it's also
got this extra emotional equality to it
that gives it this extra resonance and
reminds you about
his legacy and will and will never
forget about you feel like also that
like you know stan is inviting miles
into this legacy you know which I think
it was like something that meant a lot
to stand and meant a lot sod did he get
the chance to see the film he did not we
did not finish in time and and he was
not feeling really well enough at that
moment but you know we shared a lot of
material with him when we went to record
him and um and he was just thrilled with
the idea that like this thing he made so
long ago has reverberated and echoed so
many different interesting ways
[Music]